joining me now from glasgow is jack
crozier whose five-year-old sister emma
died in the dunblane massacre in 1996.
16 children died there and their teacher
was killed he is now a gun violence
prevention advocate and jack it's really
good to talk to you today thank you very
much for joining us yesterday must have
been a really tough day for you and your
family
it's tough for our family and everyone
from dunblane but it's so much harder
for everyone in america and the families
in texas are having to go through this
not just texas but all the other
communities that have to do this every
single week
is there anything that anyone can do to
help these families anything anyone can
say
that that in any way eases the pain
there's
everyone offers thoughts and prayers and
it's not enough
it's never been enough and it's never
going to be enough and the only thing
that we can do is take action
here in the uk it's hard to support
because we're not directly involved
anymore but there's communities and
there's campaigners out in america that
are doing such amazing work and they're
the ones that
need our support just now
because of course after dunblane the uk
government did bring in legislation to
change gun laws and also in australia
when there was a school shooting there
they brought in laws and both of our
countries mercifully haven't had an
event like that since but it wasn't
necessarily plain sailing to get that
legislation through was it
absolutely not so it wasn't until the
17th of december 1997 before handguns
were banned in the uk
at 645 days after dunblane that's how
long it took to get changed here in the
uk when there was such strong political
will and it takes time but america's had
time they've had so much time it happens
time and time again and now is the time
to take action
but obviously we were running an
interview with one of the republican
leaders who was very cross when our
reporter tried to put it to him that it
was an american problem and it was to do
with gun laws he said it's to do with
mental health problems
the gun lobby in america is is
incredibly popular and incredibly
powerful can you can you kind of shed
any light on that you know you obviously
looked into it a lot why is it so
powerful in america
money
it's the only thing that matters to
these people these politicians the
republicans you look at their bank
accounts you look at how they're funded
the nra funds these republican
politicians and that's where they get
all of their support and
all it takes is for every single
campaign every single politician that is
campaigning against gun control measures
look at their nra rating look how much
money they've been given by the nra to
support their campaigns and you'll see
that's exactly why they're against any
gun control legislation
so how do you think
things could change in america every
time there is a shooting like this you
know after sandy hook everybody always
says oh this is the event this is the
thing that changes things remember obama
standing up and making this really
powerful speech and biden this week
again making a really powerful speech we
even had sports leaders breaking down in
tears at press conferences
and yet nothing changes does it what
will make them change
it's got to be across the board there's
got to be a joint effort for both
republicans and democrats and it's got
to be incremental there's not going to
be one piece of legislation that fixes
this it's got to be from the bottom up
and from the top downs they've got
grassroots organizations that are
campaigning and they're doing the best
work that they can but we need to change
from the top down and the bills are
there there's a background check that's
been sitting with the senate for over a
year now and it needs to be passed and
that's that's where they've got to start
they've got to start by doing just
something that first step on the journey
and as soon as they can do that it will
start to change it's going to take so
much time but they need to make the
first steps
do you have any confidence it will
happen like for example in your lifetime
when you look at the current makeup of
the senate
you've got to have some hope
and
the hope comes from watching the
campaigners in america just now people
like manny and patricia oliver had
changed the wretch the kids after
parkland they're the most powerful
campaigners i've ever seen and these are
the people that are going to make the
changes that america needs
and when we think about about your
sister emma just tell us a little bit
about her and and how old she was when
you lost her
i never i don't have any memories of
emma she was five when she was killed
and done playing i was only two years
old
and
it's difficult having that not having
any memories of someone that you should
have there you know i'm so close with my
sister ellie and she's my best friend in
the world and not having that yeah um as
my big sister that i should have
and that's what makes me
support all of these people in america
there's so many families there's so many
brothers and sisters and parents that
have lost kids that
so senselessly lost they don't need to
have died and there's things that we can
do there's things there's changes that
can't happen that can prevent this and i
think that's the reason that i speak and
the only reason i ever you know give my
voice to these people is because
you know we've been through it and
we people don't need to go through this
anymore
jack thank you for sharing your voice
with us today jack crozier whose sister
emma died in the dunblane shooting thank
you very much
thank you